against elite offensive weapons and i
think middleton's really improved there
and again they're going to play without
a point guard this half
tucker the runner oh god the big on the
floor
comes over and tries to block the layup
attempt of pj tucker
two minutes gone by here in the fourth
hooker the drive
gets inside and the foul devin booker
looking to take it over he's got 33.
holiday out for a brief rest
booker gets an angle on tucker
shooting 91 not that time
holiday and chris paul now booker picks
him up
middleton spins using his height shoots
over it scores
you got to concentrate on trying to get
some stops
[Music]
holiday searching holiday has been in
command
all night long trying to draw the foul
paul knocks it away holland he gets it
back lay up he banks it all these are
the scrums
that often decide gains through holiday
[Applause]
hooker trying to draw the foul paul the
drive kicks it out good look for bridges
history got it
in and out
booker drives on connorton kicks it out
bridges up top crowder paul top of the
key
fires the three it's good good job on
the offensive
end ball movement turning down a good
shot for a better one
chris paul knocks down a three cuts the
lead to eighth
what a ball game in game four he has
been magnificent
here tonight in game five antenna coupon
high off the glass he banks it home
middleton looking for an opening drive
throws it up
that was kind of a half shot at value
here comes booker drives reversing packs
and hold
after 42 in game four
under six and a half remaining
attenuate the finish and the foul
lead back up to 11 largest lead for
milwaukee is 14.
chris paul finds bridges
bridges gets a good look knocks down the
three mikkel
[Applause]
chris paul drives anatol gets inside
scores
they've got it to six well
yana switches on i mean that is a
tremendous
he's played 41 minutes already
[Applause]
crowder comes up to crowd him shot clock
at six
middleton two-pointer puts it in and the
foul
chris middleton a chance for a
three-point play
and the lead back up to nine
jumper by middleton
[Applause]
[Music]
chris paul finds a spot three-pointer
got it
[Applause]
you see the previous screen no
communication allowing chris paul
to step in rhythm at the three-point
line you got to be up on that screen
in position to switch you don't and you
pay the price
holds back middleton wants it good ball
denial how middleton comes out to get it
on the drive step back three punter
that's good
crowder up top to booker
booker drives on giannis gets inside
scoop lamp is good
fucker's got 37. through holiday better
offense by booking fading away
over the contest nothing but bottom
wow
mr pair crowder the rebound
paul makes his move gets inside the
running layup is good
it's a one point booker the drive gets
inside
leans in knocked away and stolen by
holiday
phoenix has to foul ball throws it down
and a foul giannis on the alley-oop
what a turnaround a chance to take the
lead and the turnover
as the bucks now up by three and a free
throw gets into the pitcher comes up
with the strip
turning the basketball over and then off
to the races
could have held it out instead made the
right read throws it up where only
giannis can catch it
finishes it with the contact and bad
decision to foul because this would make
it
a four-point game with 13.5 remaining
phoenix still has a timeout